Shark attacks, mid-air collisions, and
plummeting to their death. Unfortunately,
these stunt actors lost their lives
making these movie scenes a reality.
Harry O'Connor, who served as a stunt
double for Vin Diesel in "xXx," died on
the Prague set of the film while performing a
paragliding stunt in his place. An experienced
skydiver and stunt performer who'd joined
the industry after retiring as a Navy SEAL,
O'Connor reportedly collided with a pillar
of the Palacky Bridge while paragliding
and broke his neck in the process before
passing away. It was his second effort to
complete the stunt, the first of which
was successful and used in the movie.
Director Rob Cohen later
said on his commentary track,
"We had 500 stuntmen involved with this picture;
499 didn't get a scratch. It shows you the lengths
to which we will go to bring this kind of
intense experience to the viewer. Stuntmen
know they are in danger. They make their
living through danger. Most of the time,
it's all right. Sometimes,
unfortunately, it isn't."
O'Connor was 44.
"You are America's best. Make us proud."
Stunt pilot Art Scholl had become internationally
renowned for his aerial stunt work in films like
"Blue Thunder" and "The Right Stuff" before he was
selected to complete an inverted air stunt that
would become a big part of the storyline in "Top
Gun." According to The Los Angeles Times, Scholl
was heard relaying his in-air troubles during
production on the scene, saying on his radio,
"I've got a problem here."
Scholl was highly skilled at the maneuver,
so colleagues concluded that there must
have been a mechanical failure that
caused his vessel to crash. However,
neither he nor his plane were recovered
from the debris, despite a search effort,
so the details leading up
to his death are unknown.
The mystery that surrounds the
failure that cost him his life
still lingers with his widow, Judy
Scholl, who told The Daily Mail,
"Art didn't say what the problem was. This is
the one thing I'm not happy about with him.
So I don't know if he had a control failure,
where maybe the camera jammed into the flight
controls. Or whether he had an issue with
the flight controls where he wasn't able
to get the airplane out of the flat spin or
whether he was disorientated. He didn't say."
Scholl was 53.
In one of the grisliest accidents to ever
occur on a Hollywood set, stuntman Jose Marco,
a double for Burt Reynolds, was brutally attacked
by a real-life shark while shooting an underwater
scene for "Shark!" Marco was filming alongside
a subdued bull shark in scuba gear when a great
white managed to make it through the nets
protecting the area from the rest of the sea
and charged at the camera crew before launching at
Marco and disemboweling the actor where he swam.
Crew members tried to steer the shark away from
Marco with spears, but the animal was undeterred,
and the stuntman's resulting injuries were
so severe that he died shortly after being
transported to the hospital. The incident
was catastrophic, but producers wanted to and
ultimately did use the footage of Marco's death
in the movie, along with publicizing the incident
as a marketing push. Director Samuel Fuller
was so disgusted that he disavowed the movie,
unsuccessfully attempting to have his name
removed from its credits. Marco was 32.
The Vancouver, Canada set of "Deadpool 2" became
the site of a tragedy in August 2017 when a stunt
woman named Joi "SJ" Harris was killed while
attempting to complete a motorcycle sequence
for the film. Harris was substituting for
actress Zazie Beetz as the character Domino
and was not wearing a helmet during the scene
in question to match the character. Harris
had successfully completed the stunt four
times in a row, but on the fifth attempt,
she lost control of the vehicle and went
airborne before careening into a glass building.
Local news crews reported that she was
treated on site by paramedics after the
incident, but was later taken to the
hospital and ultimately declared dead.
In a statement, a rep for 20th
Century Fox said of the incident,
"We are deeply saddened by the
accident that occurred on the
set of 'Deadpool 2' this morning. Our
hearts and prayers are with the family,
friends and colleagues of our crew
member during this difficult time."
Lead actor Ryan Reynolds echoed that sentiment,
writing on X, formerly known as Twitter,
"We're heartbroken, shocked and devastated
... but recognize nothing can come close to
the grief and inexplicable pain her family
and loved ones must feel at this moment.
My heart pours out to them — along with each
and every person she touched in this world."
Angela Bassett's double in "Vampire in Brooklyn"
had invited her mother and siblings to the set
of the film to watch her work on the day her
life was cut short. Sonja Davis' mother Wanda
Sapp would later reveal that she overheard
her daughter casting doubt on the safety of
the stunt she was about to perform during their
fateful visit, telling The Los Angeles Times,
"The last words I heard my baby say was when
she yelled down to the stunt coordinator,
'Are you sure?' I could feel Sonja
wasn't comfortable with the stunt."
Davis had been performing a 42-foot backward
jump off a building, but rather than landing
safely on the airbag that was supposed
to cushion her fall, she instead bounced
back into the building before making impact
with the ground, much to her family's horror.
Her mother initiated a multi-million dollar
wrongful death suit against the studio,
Paramount Pictures, along with director
Wes Craven and producer/star Eddie Murphy,
but the case was ultimately dismissed.
Stunt coordinators on the film would
later claim in an oral history of the movie
that Davis didn't perform the jump correctly,
but there were also no ambulances on
set during the incident. Davis was 32.
"One More! Rest in pieces."
The "Expendables" movies were envisioned as
a vehicle for pure action-driven spectacle,
bringing together the biggest stars in
the genre. Led by Sylvester Stallone,
the films have featured such heavyweight action
heroes as Arnold Schwarzenegger, Bruce Willis,
Chuck Norris, Jet Li, Wesley Snipes, and many
more. But with all that action comes the increased
risk of disaster, and tragically that's just
what happened on the set of "The Expendables 2."
During production of a second unit
water scene on Lake Ognyanova, Bulgaria,
stunt actor Kun Liu was killed and fellow
double Nuo Sun was severely injured when a
planned explosion went awry. The pair were riding
on an inflatable rubber raft at the time. Liu
was reportedly doubling for Stallone himself,
while Sun was subbing for Jet Li in the second
unit shot. Liu was just 26 at the time of his
death and the film was dedicated to his memory.
Sun managed to survive his serious
injuries and filed suit against
Sylvester Stallone and Millennium
Films for damages. The family of Liu,
meanwhile, also pursued wrongful death damages
against the parties responsible for the movie,
including stunt coordinator Chad Stahelski,
who went on to direct the "John Wick" films.
In 2017 it was reported that the plaintiffs
were awarded $195,000 Hong Kong dollars,
while Jet Li himself gave $5.8 million
Hong Kong dollars to the stuntman's family.
Written and directed by the late schlock auteur
Albert Pyun, the 1982 sword-and-sandal adventure
"The Sword and the Sorcerer" starred Lee
Horsley as Prince Talon, who learns he's
descended from noble blood and must take on a
powerful and evil wizard. Though it's not one
of that decade's most memorable movies in the
genre, it made the news after one of the film's
performers — 37-year-old John Hale "Jack" Tyree
— died in a stunt gone wrong during production.
Tyree was a veteran of the industry who'd
worked on everything from "Escape From New
York" to "History of the World: Part I." He was
filming a scene in Hollywood's Griffith Park for
"The Sword and the Sorcerer," in which he was
to jump from an 80-foot cliff. He unfortunately
landed a few feet away from the airbag intended
to cushion his fall, causing severe injuries
that eventually cost him his life. As reported by
The Calgary Herald, an official said at the time,
"It was definitely a high-risk stunt. But
Jack was a real professional. He had some
more difficult high falls before, tougher than the
one he faced [on 'The Sword and the Sorcerer']."
Perhaps surprisingly, the stunt
itself was left in the film,
despite Tyree's tragic passing, and the
film was dedicated to him in the credits.
The James Bond franchise has built a reputation
for its impressive stunts and elaborate action
sequences. Each film in the series seems to
attempt to top the one before it, and to do
that can sometimes mean making the stunts riskier
and riskier. But by the time the franchise got to
its 12th entry in 1981, "For Your Eyes Only,"
the risk-taking may have gone a little too far.
To create one skiing and bobsledding chase that
takes place amidst the wintery slopes of Italy,
the film involved the use of a four-man bobsled,
operated by the second unit director to better
capture footage of the action. Unfortunately,
23-year-old Italian stunt driver Paolo
Rigoni fell off the sleigh and was quickly
killed after it overturned and dragged
him underneath. It wasn't the first or
last serious injury to happen on the set of
a James Bond film, but it was the deadliest.
It's been reported that it was his death — along
with the death of professional bobsledder James
Morgan just a week earlier during the 1981
bobsled world championships — that prompted
the decision to shorten the Cortina bobsledding
track, where Rigoni was killed, to make it safer.
Filmmaker John Woo was one of the
hottest action directors of the '90s.
After a string of groundbreaking
features in his native Hong Kong,
Woo was wooed by Hollywood and came over to
helm such favorites as "Hard Target," "Broken
Arrow," and "Face/Off." By the late 2000s,
he was back directing smash hits in China,
and one of his first in his return to his homeland
was "Red Cliff," starring Tony Leung. It was the
highest-grossing movie of the year in the Middle
Kingdom but came at the cost of a stuntman's life.
A period piece about the battle of China's
Three Kingdoms, the set of the film became
a deadly inferno when a blaze overtook the
production, claiming the life of stuntman
Lu Yanqing and injuring six other crew
members. The accident took place during a
ship battle scene in Xiaotang Shan, just outside
of Beijing. During the filming of the sequence,
a smaller vessel engulfed in flames was planned
to collide with a larger ship. But high winds
carried the fire to the second ship and the flames
spread uncontrollably, injuring those onboard and
killing Yanqing. A statement from the U.S. studio
Lion Rock, which was co-financing the film read,
"The crew of 'Red Cliff' is deeply
distraught and full of regret."
"Comes a Horseman" was a 1978 Western starring
Jane Fonda, James Caan, and Jason Robards.
Robards starred as Jacob "J.W." Ewing, a rancher
who wants to protect his sprawling valley from
big business tycoons who would try to exploit it
for its natural resources. Working as Robards'
stunt double was stunt actor Jim Sheppard,
who had a wealth of experience on Westerns
like "The Wild Bunch" and "Hour of the Gun," and
even sci-fi outings like "Planet of the Apes."
In "Comes a Horseman," Sheppard was filming a
scene in which he was supposed to be dragged
behind a galloping horse through a fence to
simulate the death and disappearance of Robards'
character. However, the horse didn't stick to the
straight path through a gate as planned, and the
unexpected equine maneuvers caused Sheppard to be
thrown off, with his head striking a fence post.
While he survived the initial blunt head trauma,
he died not long after being hospitalized. The
incident sadly occurred on one of the last days
of filming. Although the scene did cut away from
the fatal collision, the 41-year-old Sheppard's
last stunt was still included in the picture.
"Hi guys! Colonel McCoy. I
was just in the neighborhood."
Though mostly known for his martial arts
movies, Chuck Norris made plenty of military
action flicks in the '80s, with "Delta
Force" being one of his most memorable.
A surprise cult hit that co-starred
Lee Marvin, it got a sequel in 1990,
"Delta Force 2: The Colombian Connection."
For the follow-up, it was Norris headlining
the action alone as Major Scott McCoy. But
like many other action films, "Delta Force
2" also saw a deadly helicopter crash during
filming that took the life of a stunt actor.
This time, it was in the Philippines,
where the action sequel was shooting,
and it sadly wasn't just stuntman Geoff Brewer
who lost his life in the crash. Alongside him
were pilots Don Marshall and Jojo Imperiale,
cameraman Gadi Danzig, and key grip Mike Graham.
Though only three men died at the scene, at
least two more succumbed to their injuries,
of the nearly a dozen people hospitalized
after the accident. To make matters worse,
the production company — notorious low-budget
studio Cannon Films — had seen the deaths of
at least 10 people while filming numerous
projects over the course of four years.
Another film in a long line that saw deadly
helicopter crashes during production,
"Hired to Kill" is — like "Delta Force
II" — a low-budget action movie from 1990,
this one starring Brian Thompson, George Kennedy,
and Oliver Reed. Thompson plays a mercenary who
poses as a photographer when he's hired to rescue
a freedom fighter being held behind enemy lines.
During filming the year before the movie hit
theaters, a helicopter being used to shoot a
mid-air scene crashed, injuring the pilot and
several others, and killing a stunt actor.
The actor, Clint Carpenter, had been
a regular stuntman on the kid's action
series "V.R. Troopers," and was riding with
a pair of fellow stuntmen. While performing
what was later described as a "routine fly-by,"
moving across the camera's field of vision — set
up on a rooftop — the vehicle attempted to
make a tight turn. For unexplained reasons,
the helicopter failed to achieve the
turn and crashed into a group of trees,
killing Carpenter, who was pronounced dead
before he even made it to a nearby hospital.
Passengers Michael Kane, pilot Marc Wolff,
and stunt coordinator Mark Cuttin, along with
a third unknown stuntman, all sustained injuries.
Though they suffered broken ribs, a leg fracture,
and a punctured lung among them, they
were able to escape with their lives.
"Houston, we have a problem."
Before "Apollo 13" in 1995, it was 1983's "The
Right Stuff" that held the title for best film
about NASA's space flight program. Oddly
enough, that movie also included "Apollo
13" actor Ed Harris, who plays astronaut John
Glenn. It recounts the years that led up to the
launching of the Mercury 7, beginning when
Chuck Yeager first broke the sound barrier
and includes all the incredibly dangerous
exploits of test pilots like Yeager, Glenn,
and Alan Shepard. The film features several
incredible high-flying stunts, and one of
them involves a pilot parachuting to safety
from the confines of an experimental aircraft.
Unlike in the movie, though, the pilot never
did make it home safely. Performing the scene
was stunt actor and Houston native
Joseph Svec, both a veteran of the
profession and a qualified parachutist.
But during the filming of the ejection,
Svec inexplicably failed to pull his ripcord, the
parachute never opened, and he plummeted to his
death. According to a manager of the California
City Airport where the scene was being filmed,
an investigation revealed that nothing was
wrong with Svec's chute, suggesting that it
was either a simple error by Svec or that he
somehow lost consciousness during the plunge.
In the 1930s, Jack Budlong wasn't strictly a
stunt performer; he was also a professional
horseman and actor. But for the 1941 movie
"They Died With Their Boots On" — a Civil
War classic about General Custer that
starred Errol Flynn, Olivia de Havilland,
and Gene Lockhart — Budlong was brought in for
the film's sprawling war scenes. Reportedly,
Budlong played both Union and Confederate
soldiers at various points in the production,
and it was during one sequence when he was in the
Southern grays that the horse rider was killed.
Budlong, who is said to have been
a close personal friend of Flynn,
had persuaded the star into getting him a role
as a stunt-performing extra during the film's
war scenes. Not much of a veteran stunt
actor, though, Budlong's inexperience may
have been what led him to insist on using
a real saber rather than a prop. So when,
during filming, his horse began bucking due to
the simulated artillery exploding around them,
Budlong was tossed off the animal and landed
right on his very real, very sharp blade.
Budlong was taken to a Los Angeles
hospital, but it was far too late for him:
the saber had punctured his abdomen and
exited via his back. He wasn't the only
casualty of filming, though, as the
production of "They Died With Their
Boots On" led to countless injuries and
at least two more deaths besides Budlong.
"Do you know what is there, waiting beyond
that beach? Immortality! Take it, it's yours!"
Brad Pitt's 2004 ancient war movie
"Troy," directed by Wolfgang Peterson,
adapted Homer's "Iliad," the epic poem that
depicted the historical Trojan War waged between
the Greeks and the Spartans. Its filming was also
a massive undertaking and a throwback to epics
of the '50s and '60, which meant it had several
large-scale action sequences involving hundreds
of extras. It also led to the death of one of
the many stunt actors involved in the production.
Stuntman George Camilleri was admitted to a
hospital during filming with "serious trauma"
to his ankle, according to the Times of Malta,
while also suffering chest pains and shortness
of breath. He underwent surgery, but two days
later he was dead. Though initially it wasn't
realized that his death had been related to an
on-set accident, a later inquiry traced the cause
of Camilleri's death all back to injuries he'd
sustained while filming an action scene on "Troy."
An autopsy revealed that Camilleri's death
was caused by pulmonary thromboembolism,
with the report stating,
"Pulmonary thromboembolism is not an
uncommon complication following trauma,
fracture of the lower leg, surgery
to the lower limb and immobility."
According to the investigation, the initial
injury occurred when Calmierri had been
jumping over the side of a galleon. But
mixed signals between extras led to him
making an error and jumping from the wrong
spot, which he hadn't been prepared for.
The 1965 film "The Flight of the Phoenix"
starred James Stewart as a pilot whose
plane crashes in the Sahara. Desperately
trying to keep himself, his crew and his
passengers alive in the remote desert, his
only hope is a passenger whose experience
as an aircraft designer has him convinced they
can build a new plane out of spare parts from
the wreck. It's a nail-biting tale of adventure
and survival, but in the making of the movie,
a famed stunt pilot who was hired to make
risky aerial maneuvers lost his life.
An experienced racing pilot who'd
worked in Hollywood since the 1930s,
Paul Mantz was well-known for helping
Amelia Earhart and her navigator Fred
Noonan prepare for their first attempt
to circumnavigate the globe. He was
practically pilot royalty in his day,
but that didn't mean he was invincible.
During filming of "The Flight of the Phoenix," he
was flying low in a sequence meant to simulate a
take-off when something went wrong and the
plane crashed, killing him. Ironically,
it wasn't even Mantz who was supposed to be
behind the controls that day, but his partner
Frank Tallman. At the last minute, though,
Tallman injured his knee and Mantz filled in.
With Mantz's death, "The Flight of the
Phoenix" may have been a cursed production:
In 2004, Dennis Quaid starred in a remake
that seriously injured cameraman Ciaran
Barry. He received a million-dollar
settlement, though no one was killed.
Movies about dangerous professions are
inherently going to involve precarious stunts,
so when it came time to film a story
about the construction of a skyscraper,
there was extra danger involved. Experienced
stuntman A.J. Bakunas was doubling for lead
actor George Kennedy on the Lexington, Kentucky
set of "Steel" when tragedy struck. In the scene,
he attempted a daring drop that
would feature him plunging from
the top of a high-rise to simulate the
falling death of Kennedy's character.
Bakunas was a well-known name in the industry
long before he went to work on the film. By all
accounts, he had been preparing for the jump for
weeks and decided to increase the length of his
fall to 323 feet instead of the ninth-story leap
he'd already completed. He wasn't doing it to make
the stunt more impressive, but instead simply
hoping to top a stunt performed on another set
by rival stuntman Dar Robinson — who was still
nearly a decade away from his own fatal stunt.
Bakunas completed the jump as planned, but the
airbag below ruptured, injuring him critically
right in front of a massive crowd of spectators
who had assembled to watch the stunt. The actor
was still alive and conscious as he was
rushed to the emergency room and treated,
but he eventually succumbed to
his injuries. Bakunas was only 27.
"One thing I'd like to know. Are
world records worth the risk?"
Movies involving high-flying aircraft action can
be fraught with danger and typically require the
skills of talented stunt pilots who can pull off
death-defying maneuvers. That was the case with
"Von Richthofen and Brown," a 1971 World War I
epic about one of the greatest flying aces that
history has ever known. A passion project for
director Roger Corman, who put up much of the
financing himself, the film was shot in Ireland
and told the story of Manfred von Richthofen,
also known as "The Red Baron," and the pilot Roy
Brown, who took him down. Filming the intense
dogfights, though, led to a mid-air collision
that killed stuntman Charles Boddington.
Following the incident, the Irish
government decided to shut down the
production's aerial scenes that Corman
had scheduled for Weston Airfield,
not far from Dublin. According to contemporary
accounts, Boddington's disastrous crash in
the sky wasn't even the last accident during
filming. Just a day later, pilot Lynn Garrison
and actor Don Stroud received injuries after an
unscheduled crash landing in the Liffey River.
It probably isn't much of a surprise to learn
that there have been some mishaps on the sets
of movies starring Arnold Schwarzenegger. After
all, the overly-muscled body builder-turned-actor
is known for his explosive action movies,
from science fiction and fantasy to military
thrillers. In 1988, filming on his buddy cop
action-comedy "Red Heat" went a little too far
even by Arnold's standards, resulting in
the death of stunt actor Bennie Dobbins.
The film, which was dedicated to Dobbins,
had Arnold in the role of a Russian military
captain named Ivan Danko. He's sent to
Chicago where he teams up with a local cop
after they realize they're both looking for
the same criminal. Filled with guns-blazing
shootouts and bare-knuckle brawls, "Red Heat"
is an underrated Arnie classic. But filming
one scene that involved the "Terminator" star
duking it out hand-to-hand with a stunt man,
who wasn't Dobbins, led to a
death in an unexpected way.
During the scene, Dobbins was serving as
the stunt coordinator, helping stage the
scene with his two actors when he suddenly
collapsed. Suffering a fatal heart attack,
Dobbins was airlifted to a local hospital
but didn't survive. He was 55 years old,
and left behind work in many action classics like
"First Blood," "Commando," and "The Running Man."
"It's time to start running!"